foreign
[Music]
to you on this Sunday it is a very
special day of worship put your foot
down the body and the blood of our Lord
Jesus Christ
where's Catherine Sheila
for God your blood was spilled and has
flown through the ages of time
but we know
that father
bothered because of that blood we were
saved one day and claimed Heaven as our
home
Catherine
praise thank you you're not in Jesus
name amen the body in the blood
the body in the blood
Catherine the body and the blood the
body
[Music]
[Applause]
I don't want to go to hell
rated R only in theaters October 6th
don't be scared
we've met before
are you looking for Reagan are you
looking for Reagan
three times again
[Music]
what do you think evil is
I'll tell you what I think it is
we're born in this world with Hope and
Dreams
and a desire to be happy
foreign
it's happening to my daughter too the
devil has one wish Wherever those girls
went they brought something back with
him
to make us lose faith I believe you can
help get our daughters back to kill it
in us and the devil never gives up
she knows who I am
where's the other girl
I feel
what you're doing here is
that people have died on both sides of
possession
come on baby
mama what is it baby
I'm right here
there are two heartbeats isn't working
they're beating in sync
what did you do
one girl lives one girl dies
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign